as Americans expand their palates many
are beginning to discover new kinds of
fish to eat it is beneficial in more
ways than one new tastes new ways to
keep fisheries stocked and the best way
to support local fishermen along the
forefront of this movement is a team of
anglers and chefs in Charleston South
Carolina that's where we went to get an
up-close look at the future of fishing
and what ends up on your plate when I
first got the Charleston every menu had
grouper snapper salmon even though it's
not from here
but there weren't that many species that
people were familiar with Mike Latta
first opened fig in Charleston South
Carolina
in 2003 it is since 1 3 James Beard
Awards and is considered one of the top
restaurants in the world
Latta followed fig with the ordinary
which features an all seafood menu
nobody was talking about seafood and
here we are on the coast
this is Charleston how is it possible
people weren't talking about seafood I
think everybody kind of pays attention
to what's trending and nationally
nose-to-tail cooking was very popular
for a decade getting in whole hogs and
learning how to break them down and I
just think for some reason that was
where everybody's attention was turned
seafood was still popular in Charleston
but you know we really weren't that
connected to the people producing it
lada has dedicated his work to staying
as close as he can to the seafood he
serves what is this this is a yellowfin
yellowfin tuna here captain mark Markov
goes boat just brought in a yellowfin
tuna joint rasa yeah yeah it doesn't get
any fresher than this sliced and served
just off the dock place at the top of
the line right here is for me the best
raw stuff
yeah do it oh yeah yeah great right like
the sex was really nice very yeah
yes yes tuna is well known other fish
are not anytime we're expecting or
demanding from the ocean the same five
or six species we're not acknowledging
the diversity of the species that are
coming up in a fisherman's net
conservationists like Amy McCown who we
met aboard a small independent shrimp
boat are trying to turn the time there's
so many underutilized species that are a
part of our ecosystem and can be relied
on as a sustainable source of protein
McCown works for good catch a nonprofit
that connects restaurants with local
fishermen
that means fishermen being open to
different catches it means people when
there are restaurants being open to
eating different fish absolutely
fishermen are waiting they are ready for
people to say yeah I want I want to eat
scup or a few years ago here in
Charleston it was wreck fish I mean
they're these species out there and
fishermen are just waiting for them to
actually be demanded enough that they
bring something and they bring a value
back at the dock McCown says looking
local and in season is key
ideally consumers should also be able to
find out where their fish was caught how
and by whom ninety nine percent of
people who are buying fish at their
local market aren't getting that
information you're right what we see
when people go into the grocery stores
they go to the fruit section they know
they want no GMOs they don't then they
want organics when they go to the beef
and eggs they want grass-fed free-range
when they go to the seafood counter they
say all right what's on sale and so how
do we spread those values of the other
areas of the market into the seafood
counter and that is through having
conversations like this why hasn't that
conversation reached the seafood counter
yet and I think it's because seafood and
fisheries is just so complex
in Charleston progress is being made now
in Lauda's restaurants fish most of us
haven't heard of our hits we can sell
amberjack we can sell porgy Sheepshead
rudder fish there's a host of species
that you would never have seen on a menu
20 years ago that you do now and the
good thing is is that people are much
more adventurous in his kitchen Lauda
cooked us a fitting arrangement a good
way to do it is go to a restaurant that
you trust and let them make something
new for you okay so this is cello Bray
is direct fish buried this is a hog
snapper with red line ponzu smoked
amberjack pate and then one of my
favorites is the peony trip these are so
clean right sweet fishing in fish right
is the only wild foods that we eat my
interest in seafood cookery was born
from the diversity of species that we
get in on a daily weekly basis and to
imagine my world without the pleasure of
that variety of seafood I don't know
where I would find my inspiration
snuck in the wine there was someone you
have to it accompanies the seafood it
was a fun shoot to be on another tip
from all the folks who live down there
all over is if you can avoid eating
imported fish and seafood doing nothing
against other oceans around the world
but the regulations are far less
stringent in other parts of the world
you're also freezing them and
transporting them 90% of the shrimp that
gets served in the US is imported 90% to
correct what's so hard about seafood too
is it's just more expensive so you know
when you do go to the counter you're
looking for the cheapest price but you
know we all have to educate ourselves
the first and easiest thing to ask for
it's just what's local right if
something is local a really good point
you